when I cross the finish line or clear a
bar there's no feeling like it I it's
like a sigh of relief and excitement
like all at the same time and you see
like when I was really training I would
train like four or five hours a day all
for that one moment
coach town almost ruined becoming Mills
Dale because when he called me I found
out on the phone that he didn't know I
was a bull vaulter
so he's recruiting me just for sprinting
in we're talking about and somehow I
like caught on and I was like you know
I'm a pole vaulter right like I have the
state record and I've won state like
three times and coach town like covered
the phone up it's like looked over to
coach Bo and was like so she's a pole
vaulter and I think coach Bo had the
same thought of like okay he said to me
coach town please just come to Hillsdale
once and then I'll never call you again
I'm like okay that sounds like a deal
I'll make that deal I'll make the time
I'll come to Hillsdale and take care of
this and this guy won't call me again
and then I went up to Hillsdale and just
fell in love with the place when I got
the division to record I didn't know it
was the record at the time actually I
I'm weird I don't focus on things like
that so like I just knew I jumped higher
and I was elated like every meet you
wanted to do well for Hillsdale like you
wanted Hills know to have a good name
and you wanted to bring your team up and
have your team be one of the best in the
country the four-by-four was so special
to me because it was a team thing I
believe we had two seniors on it and
then me and my friend Erin were freshmen
at one of our last meets of the season
we ended up qualifying for Nationals and
we were like the last people to get in
or second to last like barely got it we
ended up going from coming in as one of
the last people to getting an
all-american title in that race I have a
picture somewhere of me puking in a
trash can and like this bumping there
and one of those seniors is like patting
my back and that just summed it all up I
got married last year last August to
love my life Adam
actually we were both pole vaulters in
high school so we met because of track
and field to be inducted in the
Hillsdale Hall of Fame means a ton to me
it means the world when I think about
Hilda I think about all the things he'll
don't gave me what the coaches the
facility is like all the staff there
everybody gave me so much they helped me
every step of the way
to accomplish everything I wanted to
accomplish so for them to want to
celebrate me for something it's it's
incredible